2020 might feel far away but Hollywood's
major studios are already planning ahead
and it's looking like it could be an
incredibly exciting year for the film
industry here are the most hotly
anticipated movies coming out next year
17 years after the release of bad boys
to audiences we'll finally get to see
another entry into the classic buddy-cop
franchise sony has slated bad boys for
life for January 17
2020 bringing back Will Smith and Martin
Lawrence as Miami Police Department
detectives Mike Lowrey and Marcus
Burnett Jerry Bruckheimer is set to
return to produce the project which will
be directed by Adil LRV and Villa Falah
bad boys for life has had a long and
difficult journey to the big screen and
many fans thought that it would never
even happen especially when the movie
was pulled from the studio's release
schedule and lost its initial director
due to scheduling conflicts but it
appears that it's finally moving forward
now and should mark a fun new
opportunity for fans to enjoy the action
Adventures of Smith and Lawrence once
again we may not have any specific
details on the movie's plot yet but
we're still pumped the follow up to 2014
Spectre has endured as rough a road as
any entry in the franchise's 5 decade
history it was uncertain for a while if
Daniel Craig would even return for his
fifth on-screen mission while acclaimed
Trainspotting director Danny Boyle
initially took and then promptly stepped
out of the director's chair now however
some details about double-oh-seven 25th
cinematic outing are finally becoming
clear Craig will indeed return one last
time in a film by true detectives cary
fukunaga the first american director to
helm a Bond movie intriguingly Craig's
tenure as Bond has been marked by a
distinct back and forth critical
reception middling reactions to Quantum
of Solace and Spectre punctuated
overwhelming a claim for Casino Royale
and Skyfall so following that pattern
this movie is set to become a rousing
success important details such as the
film's title and who will perform the
theme song have yet to be announced but
we do know that bond 25 will hit
theaters on Valentine's Day 2020 are you
ready to get back to work
[Music]
with pleasure and
with pleasure after greeting it up for
Marvel's guardians of the galaxy movies
Vin Diesel is shifting gears for a
different sort of comic book film The
Fast and Furious actor will step into
the lead role in Sony's upcoming
bloodshot movie adapted from Valiant
Comics successful comic series of the
same name the lead character is a
wounded soldier who's been resurrected
through the wonders of nanotechnology
and now he has to hunt down powerful
outcasts called harbingers the comic
premiered in 1992 and ran for 110 issues
with upwards of 7.5 million copies sold
now with the success of violent comics
derived films like Logan and Deadpool
valiance and Sony will surely be
striving for an R rating given this
hero's taste for blood we'd expect
nothing less blood shot will be helmed
by a visual effects artist and
first-time director Dave Wilson and will
co-star a Segen solace Michael Sheen
Toby Kebbell and Sam heughan and is due
out February 21st fans may have to wait
an extra year for Fast and Furious 9 but
they'll get a spin-off movie out of
Dwayne Johnson and Jason Statham in the
meantime and Hobbes and Shaw should be
worth the wait when it finally does hit
theaters in the spring of 2019 although
we don't know much about where the main
SOG is headed next the pressure to keep
upping the stakes should mean it'll find
a way to be even more epic and
ridiculous than any of the previous
installments with Charlize Theron cipher
still alive and on the loose at the end
of the fate of the Furious there are
plenty of existing opportunities for
vehicular mayhem you can probably count
on most of your favorite cast members
returning - and the franchise's
ever-increasing profile means there's
always the chance to land even more big
names to join the cast fast and furious
9 is due for release on April 10th 2020
film fans will finally get the answer to
an age-old question on May 22nd 2020
when Godzilla and King Kong face off on
the big screen director Adam Wingard has
already assured fans that his take on
the two monsters will crown a definitive
winner
unlike the 1962 film that first pit the
two characters against each other this
will be the fourth entry in the
legendaries monster verse first
established in 2014's Godzilla
the EE wheeze won't speak their name but
i call them skull brawlers why because
it sounds neat and further expanded on
with Kong Skull Island Godzilla king of
the monsters will open that world even
wider in 2019 bringing old favorites
like Mothra and Rodan into the fray and
setting the stage for this next Clash of
the Titans Godzilla vs. Kong is the
biggest project yet for Wingard whose
previous directing credits include your
next and the guest as if the collision
of these two screen icons wasn't fan
pleasing enough the movie will also
feature an impressive lineup of human
actors stranger things Millie Bobby
Brown will reprise her king of the
monsters role with Black Panthers Danai
gurira in Deadpool twos Julian Dennison
also attached to star audiences haven't
seen much of Angelina Jolie over the
past few years in fact her most recent
big-budget movie was 2014's Maleficent
now after four years of waiting Disney
has confirmed the return of the fairy
with the horns and the high cheekbones
announcing that Maleficent too has
started production with Jolie and Elle
Fanning reprising their roles as
Maleficent and Aurora according to the
synopsis the sequel begins several years
after the first chapter and follows the
complicated relationship between the
horned fairy and the soon to be Queen
hot off her appearance an ant-man in the
wasp Michelle Pfeiffer has signed on to
the project as Queen Ingrid Harris
Dickinson who has just finished playing
john paul Getty the third in the FX
series trust will step in to replace
Brenton Thwaites as Prince Phillip
aurorus love interest joachim ronan who
directed 2017 s pirates of the caribbean
dead men tell no tales will venture into
the enchanted forest to helm the feature
which is set to hit theaters on May 29th
2017 s Wonder Woman is the most
critically acclaimed movie in the DC
extended universe by a very wide margin
it makes sense then that gal gadot next
adventure as the Amazonian warrior is
being fast-tracked back to the big
screen floss Superman and Batman are
left to struggle against a legion of
issues and complications standing in the
way of their next movie appearances 1
this is the days when
biggest concerns were exploding wind-up
penguins
Dianna's second solo story hasn't been
without its own delays however Wonder
Woman 1984 was pushed back from its
original 2019 holiday season release to
June 5th 2020 when the movie does
finally arrive it will likely bring with
it just the kind of colorful blast from
the past its title promises filling in
part of the timeline between the first
movies world war one setting and the
heroes reemergence and dawn of justice
Wonder Woman 1984 will see the return of
gadot Chris Pine and director patty
Jenkins SNL alum Kristen Wiig also joins
the fray as nemesis cheetah who will
clash with Diana in the depths of the
Soviet Union it's pretty hard to keep a
movie production secret for very long
especially in the modern age that's why
it was so shocking when filmmaker Jason
Reitman revealed that not only was he
working on a new Ghostbusters movie but
that he already had a vague but
atmospheric teaser trailer ready
announcing its summer 2020 arrival the
son of original Ghostbusters director
Ivan Reitman Jason has formed his own
identity as a director with such offbeat
low-key drama DS as Juno and Tully now
he's ready to direct and co-write a new
chapter of the story he watched unfold
on set as a child Gale came in the
director of 2015's poltergeist remake
will be sharing writing duties with
reitman there were plenty of reasons for
fans to be a little frustrated with Paul
figs 2016 Ghostbusters reboot but it's
still a bold move for reitman to return
to the original timeline he explained to
Entertainment Weekly it's not a reboot
what happened in the 80s happened in the
80s and this is set in the present day
it remains to be seen who else will be
involved Harald Ramos passed away in
2014
rick moranis is in semi-retirement and
bill murray has long been slippery on
the topic of committing to another
sequel but then who really knows what
Bill Murray could do at any given moment
[Music]
director Joseph Kosinski made his movie
debut with 2010's Tron Legacy a sequel
for a generation that hadn't even been
born when its predecessor was made now
he's set to do it again with top gun
maverick the 20/20 follow-up to 1986 his
classic flyboy thrill ride this new
installment will find the Original
Movies hero taking the son of his fallen
friend under his wing top gun director
Tony Scott had once envisioned a sequel
to his original movie but his death in
2010 put those plans on halt
producer Jerry Bruckheimer remained
dedicated however eventually hiring
Kaczynski and securing the commitment of
original stars Tom Cruise and Val Kilmer
miles teller will play the son of goose
with Jennifer Connelly Jon Hamm and Ed
Harris also joining the cast a big part
of Top Gun success was its wildly
popular soundtrack so it's lucky that
harold faltermeyer is also returning to
compose the score with Kenny Loggins
recording a new version of danger zone
for the movie feel the need for speed on
June 26
lin-manuel Miranda has become one of the
defining songwriters and performers of
his generation not only did he earn a
Pulitzer Prize for the monumental impact
of his Broadway musical Hamilton but
he's also been a delightful presence in
family film and television meanwhile
director Jon M Chu is best known for
forging a cultural phenomenon in 2018
with crazy rich Asians combining these
two forces can only be a great idea and
that's exactly what's gonna happen in
2020 with choose adaptation of Miranda's
debut Broadway musical in the heights
the little else has been revealed about
the movie the show examines the lives of
the Hispanic American residents of the
Washington Heights neighborhood of New
York City
Miranda himself originally played the
central role of US Navy a young bodega
owner who dreams of returning to his
familial home of the Dominican Republic
after a long and troubled development
history that stretches back a whole
decade in the heights we'll finally hit
screens on June 26th the crimes of
Grindelwald may have been cursed with a
less enthusiastic critical response than
expected but it nevertheless continued
the Harry Potter tradition of conjuring
hordes of box-office gold so there's no
reason for Warner Brothers JK Rowling or
director David Yates to transfigure
their plans for a five movie fantastic
Beast franchise and the third entry
holds fast and it's slated November 20th
release date the ending of the second
movie left Newt Scamander and company
with a number of potential paths forward
unlike the original Harry Potter movies
the fantastic beasts screenplays aren't
adapted directly from books so we can't
be certain just we're rolling we'll take
her Wizarding World next she has dropped
some hints however including the
possibility that fantastic beasts 3
could take place in Rio de Janeiro a few
years after its predecessor we're
getting not one not two not even three
but four avatar sequels over the next
decades the first of which will hit
theaters on December 18th 2020 this man
of undertaking reportedly has a total
budget of over 1 billion dollars
allowing director and franchise
mastermind James Cameron to fully
embrace a slew of new technologies and
ensure that the sequels are as visually
stunning as the first chapter Cameron
isn't slouching on the story either and
the movies are said to be a family saga
about Jake Nick Terry and their children
much of avatars cast is set to return
with some making a comeback despite
their deaths in the original film
newcomers include fear The Walking
Dead's Cliff Curtis as tone owari the
leader of a clan of reef people and Game
of Thrones Oona Chaplin as vorrei a
prominent character described as strong
and vibrant a group of young actors will
take on mostly CGI roles as the younger
set of pandora residents bringing the
film a whole new challenge and hopefully
some new life as well check out some of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]